[Music]
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car got your small
inside voice in here son there's a gun
[Music]
[Music]
talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me
because if you put peace out in the
world you get peace back
i think you might be forgetting what you
do for a living
take the gun every job i do somebody
dies i'm not that guy anymore
some conflicts require a gun
[Music]
hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or grabbing
a briefcase you said you wanted simple
for your first job back it doesn't get
simpler
mine dude i don't even know you
there's nothing simple about this job
something else going on here
yeah i'm not the only one on this train
looking for this case
evan
where's the briefcase oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it was just here
we are right on settle everything that's
ever happened to you this is gonna sting
this let
that's a [ __ ] deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you tomorrow
i'm sure you want to talk this out no
particularly nice okay
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters
memory is everything
without it we are blind
[Music]
without it we leave the plate of our
world to chance
[Music]
i'm sorry to disturb you thomas but i've
just received troubling news tell me
what is it it's grindelwald
her time is closed my brothers and
sisters our world with the knuckles
begins
today
the world as we know it is coming up
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you said it wanted out on that one
out
you do know i'm a witch right
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous visit in this
century
who wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
oh
no one can know everything
not even you
what you're doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
dangerous times
favored dangerous men
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
[Music]
because you said we could reshape the
world even if we make
we mistakes try to make things right
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
there's nothing you can do to stop me
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
i trust you're enjoying your wand mr
kowalski
can i keep this
[Music]
on the outside
the five of you are villains
predators
remorseless sociopaths
oh stop you making me blush
we're the bad guys
and this is the crew mr snake serpentine
safe cracking machine imagine houdini
but with no arms jackpot yes
miss tarantula our in-house tech wizard
where'd you learn to do that mostly
youtube mr piranha he's brave crazy
and mr shark master of disguise his
greatest trick stealing the mona lisa
disguised as the mona lisa
and rounding out the crew is me the big
bad wolf we may be bad but we're so good
at it
we're out of here so long suckers
well this just got a little weird
if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic
you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life look it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would smack it in it
stab it saute this
i want you to save it
we're more than just scary villains they
love us you're such a good boy
maybe i don't want to be a what a bad
guy no no no
we'll always be bad guys
let's try something simpler i'm going to
give you a push-pull just for me no to
share this is going to taste extra sweet
nope
sucker
i'll teach you the [ __ ]
totally worth it
[Music]
oh
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
it's a curse
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
now a face of choice to hunt
and consume blood
don't die
we all have monsters within us
it's up to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st
[Music]
celia it's been a long time
they've opened the books on flight 127.
the hijackers had help from inside our
station here in vienna we need to find
out if we had a mold
[Music]
vic has me looking into flight 127. so
this is an interview i thought you were
here to see if we still had that old
spark it's old friends
oh you can do better than that
[Music]
told lovers
december 2012 paint me celia's picture i
was living the dream then flight 127
happened
the hijacking appears to have taken the
most tragic
someone in our station betrayed us what
about you they cleared me
really
if we started shouting moe that would
have been it for all of us we look at
the evidence we follow the facts are you
accusing me
we want to keep this quiet we can't
afford the embarrassment of a
prosecution if it's celia harrison i
need to know the man i send can do
what's necessary
[Music]
got her right here in front of me i can
do this clean but it has to happen now
it's the things that we don't know that
get to me
[Music]
what we had was real
wasn't it
i have been called many names
vengeance the spiky supernova but you
may call me
sorry justice
here we go
hello
hedgehog
you're never going to get my palace oh
contrera my friend
meet
knuckles i was expecting more of a fight
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the height
that wasn't too bad
seriously pretending to be batman blue
justice trademark pending
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something i could see
and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
we created an ecological disaster
ellie settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion
over nature
we're subordinate to it
come back i always come back
don't move bigger why do they always
have to go bigger
ready pg-13
mom
what is this
we need more colonies
but that's a lot more work there's
nothing the two of us can't handle
together
your life is so retro do you even have a
phone no so how do you talk to your
friends
my mom is my friend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get out
[Music]
who is this woman that's my um
that was all she had
i remember so much
screaming
i didn't want you to know her
why
some koreans believe that life's
hardships are caused by the tormented
spirits of their ancestors
amanda you okay i think there's
something wrong
is this what you want a final resting
place
chris i'm coming
[Music]
come here
what else have you been lying to me
about
all of this is for you i can't wait to
leave
i'm not going anywhere
a must here
every night
i dream the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you cannot control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his
theories he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look up
become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
[Music]
bro
it's like 7 00 am today's the day mom
they're posting the cast list for the
school play today
get it like it's a curtain
tough crowd
i've got some breaking news it's an open
audition they're making lilo and stitch
for broadway musical where would we even
sleep what about your aunt the broadway
actress you were the only toddler whose
first word was me
let's cast a musical
does anyone have a special skill they'd
like to demonstrate i can do fiddler on
the roof style knee crawls this i have
to see muzzle top
oh my gosh my pants does anybody have
any extra shorts
i'll make you proud of me okay that's
all we're gonna need
forget new york i'm just trying to
survive seventh grade
[Music]
i love that you're still acting you
remind me of like me you're literally
all i wanna be when i grow up three
weeks on broadway an apartment in new
york
queens but
i'm about to go out
you're a hundred times funnier and
quicker than i am
i didn't know you could do all that
[Music]
find your light
you're insane i'm theatrical hold up
just a second
sorry i thought we were alone you guys
are so weird
we know i'm about to go out
just getting started
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
[Music]
we got a breach in the perimeter
thank you
[Music]
what's like your mission law
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
let's get everyone home good luck
captaining
roger that
[Applause]
[Music]
we're being pursued by a
just a massive robot
[Music]
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
what is this taken am i talking
alan i'm here to save you
she is the key to finding the lost
treasure after them i am driving oh
just freaking [ __ ] pick it in place
getting you out of here why are you so
handsome my dad was a weatherman the
lost city march 25th
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs to create a
motion picture was a two second clip of
a black man on a horse
and that man is my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather
[Music]
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pitches could move
yeah skin of the game
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
what's a bear miracle
we got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
close your name
[Music]
12.
[Music]
[Music]
him
[Music]
foreign
him
[Music]
italy
[Music]
there are some
would make me out to be
the villain
of this here story let's don't let a
good thing die
[Music]
are you born with destiny
or does it just come
knocking at your door
as a young singer from memphis tennessee
give him a warm hayride welcome
[Music]
mr elvis wrestling
get a haircut buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
he was my destiny
i wish to promote you mr presley
are you ready to fly i'm ready ready to
fly
tomorrow all of america will be talking
about
they might put me in jail for walking
across the street but you're a famous
white boy
what he's saying is god-given there
can't be nothing wrong with it that's
all right senator kennedy has been shot
martin luther king has been shot to
death in memphis that's all right
tragedy but it has nothing to do with us
it has everything to do with us
[Music]
and nobody's gonna remember me
[Music]
i need to get back to who i really am
and how are yours
[Applause]
i just gotta be making the most of this
thing what i can
this could all be over in the flesh
[Music]
we are the same you and i
we are two odd lonely children reaching
for eternity
the greatest show on earth
elvis has left the building
last name first name warren jasmine guys
she got the room
legends
ancestor college is crowded with them
when you go to a school that's nearly as
old as the country you can expect to
hear a few
it can be really hard for students of
color just know i'm here
it's amazing cal
first black master very exciting it is
[Music]
so you live here too yeah
[Music]
the whole school is cursed okay you're
gonna have to try a lot harder than that
seriously it's it's real
i understand
[Music]
i went through it
can i just
this school is unwilling to see itself
for what it truly is
[Music]
i've been having nightmares you look
like you've seen a ghost
[Music]
why is this administration spending more
energy undermining my tenure
than unferreting up he's been
terrorizing the student body
you can't get away from that chasm
[Music]
it'll follow you
[Music]
it's everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
there's
[Music]
mama
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and the dad says the aristocrats
you know what to do with a bad hand job
get rid of it
come on folks let's give them a hand
what is this about
you caused the universe harm by breaking
its rules
you will no longer be allowed to meddle
with powers you do not comprehend
woe to you john constantine
you are sentenced to spend eternity in
the house of mystery
you god-like beings can be a real pain
in my
you're turning my best mates into demons
where'd you learn to use the crapper
why can't your mind be still
what's this did you think you were the
only one who wanted to torture me
[Music]